Wir sind heute mit Botschafter Bolton zusammen,
er diente in verschiedenen
Verwaltungen des Justizministeriums, und
der Botschafter des Außenministeriums, Bowden, war
Botschafter der Vereinten Nationen bei den Vereinten Nationen
und er diente Donald J. Trump als nationaler Sicherheitsberater.
Vielen
Dank für Ihre Zeit  Botschafter
freut sich, bei Ihnen zu sein Danke für die Einladung zum
Botschafter Erste Frage Ich
möchte mit einem Zitat des russischen
Außenministers Sergej Lawrow beginnen. Er hat vor
ein paar Tagen gesagt, dass es beim Krieg in der
Ukraine nicht so sehr um die Ukraine oder
nicht nur um die Ukraine geht  aber es geht um eine
neue weltordnung ähm und wie die neue
weltordnung in der zukunft aussehen
würde hat er recht ob es um die neue
weltordnung geht naja wir müssen sehen äh sicher haben die
russen eine ganz andere ansicht davon
wie sie  Ich würde gerne sehen, wie die Welt
arrangiert wird, und ich denke, sie haben in Europa seit vielen Jahren
einen Nullsummenvorschlag zwischen der NATO und
Russland gesehen. Eine stärkere NATO ist ein schwächeres Russland
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion muss es nicht so sein,
aber so haben sie es
in den letzten jahren zunehmend gesehen
und in der ukraine verhalten sie sich sicherlich so.
ich denke jedoch, dass es viel größere
auswirkungen auf europa und
amerika gibt  über den ukrainekrieg hinaus, und das
ist die
äh zunehmende enge der
beziehungen zwischen russland und china, die meiner meinung nach weltweite
auswirkungen hat
,
also was wären die auswirkungen, nun,
es ist äh das Gegenteil von äh den Tagen des Kalten Krieges,
als die Sowjetunion
der Seniorpartner darin war
Beziehung, aber ich denke, äh,
wegen vieler gemeinsamer Interessen, äh,
Russland ist ein Öl- und Gas-Exporteur, äh,
China ist ein riesiges, äh, energienegatives
Land, also ist es ein großer Importeur, das China
schon lange zuvor hochentwickelte
Waffensysteme von Russland und der Sowjetunion gekauft
hat  Das also denke ich, dass sie, wenn sie
die Welt um sich herum betrachten,
viele Gemeinsamkeiten sehen, und das erklärt
ihre wachsende Nähe, die offensichtlich
unsere Inte beeinflusst  Ruhen Sie sich
weltweit aus,
also sind wir jetzt fast vier Wochen
nach der Invasion der Ukraine durch die
Russen aus Ihrer Sicht, äh, was
lief überhaupt schief
und hätten wir
diese Invasion vermeiden können
?
Über die
Einheit der Alliierten klopfen wir uns viel auf die Schulter
für starke Sanktionen
gegen Russland, aber seien
wir ehrlich, ähm, im Moment sind wir vier Wochen in einem
Versagen der Alliierten.
Wir haben es versäumt, Russland von der
Invasion abzuhalten. Ich denke, Präsident Biden hat einen
großen Fehler gemacht  anfang dezember indem er einfach
die möglichkeit amerikanischer gewalt
vom tisch nahm, bekam er nichts dafür
es war ein ungezwungener fehler er hätte einfach
sagen können, dass alle optionen auf dem
tisch liegen und putin sich sorgen lassen können, wo
die uneindeutigkeit liegen könnte und die
sanktionen  Wir schlugen vor, dass alle nach der
Invasion stattfinden würden,
und wurden als schwach angesehen.
Die Zeit, diese Katastrophe zu stoppen,
war vor der Invasion, und
wir scheiterten, seien wir ehrlich, wir tun es nicht  haben
verbündete einheit zum thema
russische energieversorgung äh und
solange das so weitergeht äh macht putin immer noch
geld mit diesem krieg
also was war der strategische
fehler Putin zu sagen welche sanktionen
auf dem tisch liegen und welche
nicht  Tisch Nun, ich denke,
wir hätten anfangen sollen
, Putin zu sanktionieren, bevor er einmarschierte, äh, die
Leute sagen, aber meine Güte, wenn wir das
getan hätten, wäre er wirklich einmarschiert,
also welchen Unterschied hätte es gemacht
gut, ich denke, es gab einige
entwicklungen, die man
nur als positiv bezeichnen kann, dass nach
einer langen zeit ohne fortschritte bei der
einhaltung der 2014 eingegangenen zusage
aller nato-mitglieder, zwei
prozent ihres bip für die verteidigung
auszugeben, tat kanzler schultz  sich erneut zu der
Verpflichtung zu verpflichten, das ist gut, äh,
noch wichtiger,
äh, es war seine Ankündigung, dass
er F-35 kaufen würde,
und ich denke, das ist ein wesentlicher Schritt
dazu  das deutsche militär zu reparieren, wo
die flugzeuge nicht fliegen, die schiffe nicht
segeln und die panzer nicht fahren,
schau, wir haben alle viel zu tun,
und das nicht nur auf dem kontinent
europa, und das denke ich  die eigentliche
frage für amerika und europa ist
, ob wir erkennen
,
dass wir mit dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion noch nicht das ende der geschichte erreicht haben,
der
rest der welt sich immer noch stark bedroht fühlt
von
aggressiven staaten wie china
und so weiter  wir werden
uns in unserer lebensweise verteidigen wir müssen
anfangen darüber nachzudenken wie wir das machen können jetzt
die tragödie in der ukraine
macht das meiner meinung nach deutlich
was bedeutet dieser krieg in der ukraine nun
für die zukunft europas und der
welt  Ordnung, über die wir am
Anfang gesprochen haben.
Nun, ich denke, das erste, was es zeigt, ist,
dass es keine regelbasierte internationale
Ordnung gibt. Das war eine unprovozierte Aggression. Es
gibt absolut keinen Grund dafür
über die
Regeln  -basierte internationale Ordnung
zeigt, dass man nicht im Fantasieland leben kann. Es
gibt immer noch harte Männer auf der Welt.
Sie leben im Kreml.
Sie leben in der Verbotenen Stadt in
Peking. Sie sind bereit, Gewalt anzuwenden,
um ihre Ziele zu erreichen, und darüber kann man
reden  Anklagen wegen Kriegsverbrechen
alles, was Sie an diesem Punkt wollen
, es wird sie nicht davon abbringen, es hat sie bisher nicht
davon abgebracht, also ist die Frage
für uns, werden wir reagieren, werden wir
die notwendigen Schritte unternehmen
, um stark genug zu sein, um Frieden zu erreichen, aber
was können wir tun?  tun sie dies ukraine eine große stadt
wie mario paul scheint platt gemacht zu werden
andere könnten folgen wir haben 10 millionen
ukrainer vertrieben und fliehen
können allein sanktionen stoppen putin
ich glaube nicht obwohl wir
es sicherlich viel besser machen könnten wir sollten einen
pfahl durch die treiben  Herz des russischen
Energiesektors Deutschland sieht nicht so aus, als wäre
es
dazu bereit  ktion
ihrer städte
sollten wir die polnischen migs und
alle anderen migs, die wir im nato-
arsenal haben, den ukrainern zur Verfügung stellen. wir sollten
viel viel mehr tun, denke ich, ähm,
um ihnen durch verschiedene
arten von hilfe zu helfen. ich denke, die ironie
hier ist, dass wir versagt haben  um putin abzuschrecken und
putin schreckt uns jetzt ab
können sie sich ein szenario vorstellen, in dem nato-
truppen oder einzelne nato-länder
direkt in der ukraine eingreifen.
gut ich denke, wir sollten
auf jeden fall eine humanitäre flugverbotszone
im westlichen teil des landes in Betracht ziehen,
wenn sie das glauben
ein amerikanischer soldat sieht
einen russischen soldaten schielend an und
wir befinden uns plötzlich im dritten
weltkrieg, dann bekommt putin, was er will, umsonst.
das ist eine gefährliche situation,
daran besteht kein zweifel, die berechnungen sind sehr
schwierig, aber wenn die sofortige antwort
lautet, oh nein  wir werden das nicht tun, mein
gott, es könnte wladimir putin verärgern,
er gewinnt allein durch drohungen,
und das wird die ukraine nicht retten,
also haben viele leute in
europa angst  dass
wir auf dem
Weg sind, den dritten Weltkrieg zu beginnen, und
sie Angst vor einem nuklearen Angriff der
Russen haben. Sie denken, das ist eine realistische
Sichtweise.
Nun, jeder hat Angst vor dem 3. Weltkrieg,
jeder hat Angst vor einem Atomangriff.
Die Frage ist,
wie  Sie bewahren den Frieden und
wahren auch unsere Interessen,
und ich denke, wir haben das während des Kalten Krieges getan,
indem wir wirksame Abschreckungsfähigkeiten hatten.
Es ist nichts Neues in der
Welt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Europa, wenn ich das mit allem Respekt sagen darf, darauf
geachtet hat
, dass dies in den letzten 30 Jahren sicherlich
viele Länder nicht getan haben. Jetzt zahlen wir
den Preis dafür. Vielleicht hat die Tragödie in der Ukraine die Wende gebracht,
ich hoffe
es  Wie sehr sollten wir uns Sorgen machen, dass
China Russland hilft, sie haben gerade gesagt, dass
sie keine Waffen an die Russen liefern werden,
aber können
wir ihnen vertrauen?  nk
sicherlich haben sie zu diesem
Zeitpunkt eine Reihe von Vereinbarungen getroffen. Ich
glaube nicht, dass sie noch ein vollständiges Bündnis
haben, aber ich denke, China hat Russland
im Ukraine-Konflikt in vielerlei Hinsicht den Rücken frei. Ich
vermute, dass
chinesische
Finanzinstitute Kanäle für Sanktionen bereitstellen werden  Russische
Finanzinstitute, um ihre
Geschäfte auf internationalen Märkten zu
tätigen Ich habe keinen Zweifel, dass China bereit wäre,
Russland in Bezug auf
zusätzliche Käufe von Öl und
Erdgas zu unterstützen
Grenze,
anstatt sie auf Schiffe im
Persischen Golf zu verladen,
und ich vermute, dass es viele Möglichkeiten gibt
, wie China Russland militärische Hilfe leisten kann,
ohne unbedingt
Waffen über die Grenze zurückschicken zu müssen. Wie lange
können
wir in der Ukraine sehen, wie all das Desaster
passiert?  Gräueltaten passieren,
ohne etwas
gut zu machen. Ich mache mir Sorgen, solange Präsident
Biden und andere NATO-Verbündete das sagen  Es gibt
keinen möglichen Einsatz
militärischer Kräfte Wir werden keine
Flugverbotszone haben Wir werden die Migs nicht in die Ukraine verlegen
Es ist ein Wettlauf um Zeit Können wir
Waffen bekommen,
bevor die Russen die Fähigkeiten der Ukraine behandeln,
oder werden die Russen es schaffen, sie einzubringen?
Mehr Streitkräfte und mehr Vorräte
und das ukrainische Militär
zermahlen Russland ist ein größeres Land, es hat viel
mehr Vermögenswerte,
wenn dies nur so weitergeht, denke ich, dass
die reine Arithmetik sagt, dass Russland sich
durchsetzt und was von der Ukraine übrig wäre.
Ich denke, äh, würde
sich wirklich nähern  Ausmaß der
Zerstörung
im Zweiten Weltkrieg Also ähm, in Ihrem Buch Der Raum, in dem es
passiert ist, haben Sie das NATO-Treffen
in Brüssel 2018 beschrieben, bei dem
Sie der Nationale
Sicherheitsberater von Donald J. Trump waren. Wie
nahe war Trump, sich aus der NATO
zurückzuziehen?  Ich denke, alle von uns, die
mit ihm dort waren, dachten wirklich, dass wir
kurz davor standen, dass
er es tatsächlich ankündigte, und
wir arbeiteten hart daran, zu versuchen und zu verhindern, dass er es
offensichtlich tat  Ich glaube nicht, dass er
seinen Fuß über die Linie gesetzt hat
und sicherlich angedeutet hat, dass er es tun würde, aber
und es hat uns alle besorgt
darüber gemacht, ob dies in Zukunft wieder passieren könnte,
ob zum Beispiel, wenn
Trump eine zweite Amtszeit als Präsident gewonnen hätte
seine zweite Amtszeit könnte er zurückgezogen haben.
Ich denke, wenn es einen
Silberstreif am Horizont in der Ukraine gibt, äh, Tragödie, dann ist
es, dass in den Vereinigten Staaten,
äh, diese isolationistische Tendenz
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
ernsthafte Rückschläge erlitten hat, und ich
hoffe auf jeden Fall, dass sie dauerhaft sind, was
passieren wird  ob er wiedergewählt wird,
denkst du das ist hier eine echte perspektive
nein ich glaube nicht das er
2024 kandidieren wird ich glaube tief im inneren weiß er dass
er 2020 verloren hat er wird das natürlich nie öffentlich zugeben
aber er er  weiß es und er hat Angst, dass
er 2024 verlieren würde, selbst wenn er die
republikanische Nominierung bekommen würde, was meiner Meinung nach
ohnehin immer zweifelhafter wird,
also weil Trump es
mehr als alles andere hasst, als Verlierer bezeichnet zu werden,
denke ich, dass er einen finden wird  Um nicht
zu rennen, wird er
bis zum letztmöglichen Moment ununterbrochen davon reden, dann wird er,
glaube ich, versuchen, der
Königsmacher für die republikanische Nominierung zu sein,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass er eine
Vorhersage wie dies machen wird  krieg könnte enden und
wie die welt danach aussehen wird
gut ich mache mir große sorgen, dass äh dass
es noch lange nicht enden wird dass die
zermürbenden auswirkungen des
krieges noch katastrophalere auswirkungen auf die
ukraine haben äh un äh schätzt auf die  Moment,
äh, sind, dass mehr als 10 Millionen
Ukrainer ihre Heimat entweder
als Binnenvertriebene oder als Flüchtlinge
über internationale Grenzen verlassen haben, wenn der Krieg
weitergeht, kann diese Zahl nur noch zunehmen,
und dies ist eine Tragödie, die lange, lange dauern wird, um sich davon
zu erholen.
Ich sehe nicht, was Putin im Moment zuzugeben bereit ist, und ehrlich gesagt sehe ich nicht, was
Zelensky zuzugeben bereit
ist
Ich muss jetzt schnell handeln. Nun, ich denke, wir müssen diese Waffen bekommen.
Viele Leute haben
Waffen versprochen, sie müssen hinein und an
die Front gelangen, wo die Ukrainer
sie so schnell wie möglich effektiv einsetzen können,
denn wenn Russland Erfolg hat
Wenn Sie mehr Truppen und mehr Vermögenswerte
einbringen, wird sich das
Kräfteverhältnis zu ihren Gunsten verschieben
du, dass du mich hast
[Musik]